desde el Palacio de Miraflores la
vicepresidenta delsi Rodríguez
acompañada del canciller y el ministro
de defensa advirtió que Venezuela
evaluará de manera minuciosa esta
sentencia y adoptará las disposiciones
necesarias para la defensa de sus
derechos e integridad territorial dijo
además que el único mecanismo válido
para Venezuela en esta disputa que
mantiene con Guyana por el territorio es
el acuerdo de Ginebra firmado en 1966 la
vicepresidenta dijo que en los próximos
días habría un pronunciamiento de
Nicolás maduro quien además haría una
gran consulta a nivel nacional de las
implicaciones de esta sentencia denunció
también que en el territorio se estaría
explotando los recursos de manera
ilícita tres empresas por concesiones de
Guyana recordemos que Venezuela y Guyana
mantienen la disputa territorial del
ejecutivo desde el siglo 19 un
territorio que abarca unos 160.000
kilómetros cuadrados ricos en petróleo y
otros minerales más temprano en la Corte
Internacional de Justicia
anunció que con 14 votos a favor y uno
en contra rechazaba las objeciones
preliminares de Venezuela que
argumentaban que esta corte no podía
conocer del caso sin la participación de
Reino Unido la Corte Internacional de
Justicia sentenció que sí podía entender
Una disputa entre Guyana y Venezuela por
el territorio lo que significaría un
segundo revés para Venezuela en su
intento porque el máximo tribunal de
Naciones Unidas desestima el caso